another awesome interview here from
radio row of six football a guy who
probably saved a lot of fantasy football
seasons this year Marlin Mack
Indianapolis Colts Congrats man on a
breakout year it started in 2018 we kept
telling people the end of 2018 for you
is special and you can see it coming and
then this year
you really put that team on your back
yeah Thank You Man thank you for having
me glad to be here but I was a team
effort man thank you yeah
Marlon what was the season like for you
you know obviously Andrew retires that
kind of out of nowhere but you you know
had Jacobi and I think a lot of players
maybe not always the fans but players
felt good about that what was the season
like going in and no one put a little
more pressure on you honestly to make
things happen I'm gonna say put pressure
on me I say I get that to the line he
got a major part but it was different
man it was a way everybody was in shock
just like everybody's the fans yeah but
but we knew man things things gonna
happen it was just a speed bump
Frank coach my toes man go hot spring
bugs speed bumps the season man we just
gotta roll with the punches they keep
going
where were you when you heard that he
was retiring were you on the field I I
was in Sala well not when I find out did
you get like a bleacher report a pillar
or how's that work no I didn't the fan
started out in silence man the fan shot
it out and I was like I don't know if
it's to me we go get to the locker room
and then we go see was no no that's why
what was your first thought like when
she really knew it was real like you
could be you can say whatever you want
on this park yeah it was like it was
like wow but I understand the man in
this game and his things
things are tough and you got to know
when it's your time and I put so much
begging to it because you never know
when is your time and he knew it wasn't
it wasn't me how I'm gonna be done and
he's got a respect a guy like that man
cuz most time and guys think oh this is
our for I got to lead the game you love
so that's really cool yeah especially
that agent you mentioned your offensive
line I'd say you got a pretty good one
yeah obviously a guy in Quinton Nelson
out there but even Costanzo and a lot of
those players what's it been like
running behind them obvious
you know coming out of college in a
pretty good line but this is a totally
different ballpark where yeah Andy I
definitely a definitely different from
more this is crazy man cuz you just
gotta be patient as a running back but I
know I don't have to be so bad special
with my office online because they make
some pretty big hosts funny man and once
then get a clicker fuzz nobody can stop
us cuz once they again guys gonna move
and they know how guys working things
like that I just know have a good game
so always are you one of those guys the
Bisons linemen Christmas presents uh are
you waiting for their contract I
understand yeah I got up some [ __ ] but
I couldn't get him what I could truly
desire what other guys giving but so I
gave him a little something whacking off
my other contract it's the thought that
counts
yeah exactly yeah so they know that you
appreciate this yeah yeah they know
you'll get them in two years yes up so
he isn't
give him something bigger than that yeah
I always say I think coach Reich is
actually one of the more more underrated
coaches in the NFL what has he done so
far to help you grow your game you know
day three pick and that you've now
blossomed into a great great NFL running
back man this this just being a player
coach man guy that played the game
before and know how players and players
are and things like that it just helped
us with the office wise and this
learning gained so much from how he so
laid back and how you just do things man
and this that energy we just feed off
his energy and things like that and hey
how you working how you doing job what
was the moment for you whether it was in
your rookie year or after that where you
were like I've made it like I'm in the
NFL mmm is there a certain play or
certain game where you had that moment
uh yeah it's tough
I got hit a couple of times a year man
it was like what but my review was was a
great learning experience for me and
just
how to game wicks and see how fast this
game goes how much easier was your -
yeah that transition it was much easier
man I know how guys working how'd it
work in the NFL how to do your job and
learn so much from Frank man this Frank
good is what to him working no
disrespect from the game and know how to
go and prepare you week definitely big
difference the year - so what's next for
you what what are you turning it better
I mean you show this year your hands
your ability be a three down back what's
next managers overall getting better man
he's weak man you just gotta keep
getting better had that moment Batali
recipes Kobe but just gotta keep getting
better everything you do man running the
ball playing the defense's catching it
because uh you always gotta be the best
easier is their job to replace you so I
gotta make sure I keep my job no matter
whether dating how the Year goes me it's
a guy that mentality just kickin any
better at your job yeah and I don't
think they're gonna be looking to
replace it also helped out going into
year two with Jacoby he's not
familiarity with everyone yeah
definitely I mean he is for not a
fireman but going to tell you to man he
knows dolphins man is just that trusting
him like everybody got that trust in him
but your tuna often is always best best
for you when you is actually started man
and I know the big things confident he's
a hard worker and he's a great leader
man I know big things coming from
especially to have all offseason being
the guy said finding out yeah late
August that you're gonna have to be the
guy did coach Wright say anything new
about hey like this we're gonna lean on
you a little bit with this transition no
you just kept everything like like as
you just did nothing happening yeah like
not to have him yeah he just kept
calling his office and and I was the
game plan for the year men's keep
calling his office day to him and
instead ourselves and keep that trust in
Jacoby and that calm composure that's
what we always say about it nothing
really changes and you guys have such a
good group there to you know obviously T
why who's been a little banged up but a
lot of good players on the offensive
line and we hear a lot of noise this
time of year some Colts fans want them
to draft a quarterback yeah I feel like
with in the locker room there's not that
feeling you guys have a lot of faith in
Jacoby and there
definitely I mean especially with me
home real cool Jacobi man I got that
finger on them
no7 he's gonna ball out I know expecting
him I don't know from different guys cuz
I haven't been around them but yeah it
is what it is in the NFL you gotta let
them handle that part at business and
keep that over there but at 7:07 so and
you're a Florida guy yeah so you went to
school here yeah what was it like when
you got to Indy it's a little colder I
know you playin or colder but you still
gotta walk around outside what was that
transition oh man huh introduced a black
guys I was probably funny yeah crazy uh
make sure you get the start on the
ground
yeah the side on the ground I have my
actually first time really saying like
snow come down was I game I refused to
Buffalo and it was like I was like yeah
right I do not want to be here and I
like the snow but as the years kept
going by man get used to it I got my own
salt got my little thing to keep the
snow off ice scraper ice scraper get ice
cream man you're gonna be driving like a
big four-wheel-drive truck before you
know exactly ya think I'm we actually
invest more than one of these days we
spend a lot of time in D with the NFL
Combine
obviously where's the go-to spot for you
to go eat me I'm a food chain guy yeah I
like um what's the plate oh I can't dig
it a name but one little tiny spot that
I like it's kind of far from the from
the car - why it's called Tomo
great hibachi spot I love it there eat
Benihana I like I like a bite see a lot
so I eat Benihana that's closer to the
opposite mall wings when you stop yeah
eat it oh man when I can't got try to
stay healthy - so right suppose a little
rice bowl yeah but playing in a city
where there's been you know Hall of Fame
running backs marshall faulk we might
see agent James get in this weekend is
that anything that you look at it like
there's a pressure here to perform at
running back because they're used to
great running backs and
yeah it really says precious man I
actually played with all the friends so
a lot of its got the fishes on the wall
man but I try not to put the pressure on
myself man just the goddamn ball just
play play me be myself and just go ahead
and run a bottle it let's put some
touchdowns on the board
and what was it like having Frank Gore
because I feel like he's he's really
good with him back so you see were
definite area obviously was really
helpful to you so what's that's what's
it what does that like a Boz age you
won't tell that he's old man like he's
laid back do I still taking like 5 or 25
Cooley up to David everything man he
this is a very low G man disrespect the
man he could read doing things like that
but he just laid back guy he this this
this he's not scared guy but you always
can learn from a man because he's just
laid-back and gonna save much and we do
speeches listen do you think it's all
Famer oh yeah definitely for a fact if
he's just watching I mean I watched him
in practice so it doesn't running back
you watched him to smile hose you it's
amazing especially at the AZ still
toning that man it's crazy that he doing
the cam so I watched him when you were a
kid like if you watch the football
growing up you watch the French
especially I was being my boy yeah okay
yeah so I watched him a little bit as
Miami time and he had it but more I'm
had a great we've talked about you okay
he yeah cordis yeah who's a great runner
back stable man but when he got his time
to shine he bowed out there absolutely
did as did you this last year man so we
appreciate you stopped by good luck
especially with that second contract
yeah thanks moment exam